that's right I'm agent 47
don't flatter yourself shitty movie I
just had this stuff lying around and go
out and buy for the sake of reviewing
you hitman agent 47 so hitman agent 47
is keeping up the strong tradition of
making a shitty movie based off of a
good video game in this movie to have a
hitman his name is agent 47 because he's
the 47 he's genetically altered he's
smarter he's faster and he's going after
this girl this girl's going after this
guy in Zachary Quintos in the movie also
and they do this big briefing at the
beginning of the movies like oh by the
way there were agents and in this
experiment this experiment this
experiment now we're here for the sake
of catching you up to speed of this
whole plot it's so much information
overload in the very beginning they're
like alright you're supposed to care now
right and you don't you don't care at
all because in the end it's still a
shitty movie we'll talk about what's
good first of all I like the Hitman not
just because of the way he dresses the
fact is he's kind of a badass her being
so emotionless he brings the most life
into a lifeless movie but he was like
Jason Voorhees a bit the [ __ ] is just
unreal Zachary Quinto and this girl are
running for dear life they are running
this dude he never runs he just walks
you're like hey hitmen
he's pretty advantageous to keep pace
with your prey they're running their
asses off they stop they turn around and
this dude who has only been walking is
like right behind him just still walking
it's like Jason Voorhees it works for a
campy slasher flick in the age because
it was a campy slasher flick in the 80s
we're in 2015 this is a hit man it's
just it doesn't work in my mind's eye
but I did end up liking the dude in this
movie plus he has some sweet shootouts
this dude he's kind of they're
channeling their energy on wick this
dude is just shooting everybody's just
blend blend headshot headshot headshot a
headshot and you're like I love it but
it goes so far as to show how accurate
he could be shoots a gun away from a
dude to Zachary Quintos like he can't
die if he can't get shot because he has
like Kevlar skin so you're like alright
he shot the gun away from him if you can
do that you could have shot him in the
eye I'm just saying you could do that
and when you're deconstructing the movie
you're not enjoying the movie and so the
movie just it's kind of it's a wreck
because the dialogue in this movie holy
[ __ ] it's not good there's a scene where
Quinto gets stabbed into his Kevlar skin
here like flexes and breaks the knife
but he says something really cheesy
we're talking like I forgot what he said
but it was a remark that was just like
dick come on if he
not said anything it would have been
more effective you just BAM flexes and
breaks a knife or whatever the hell
happened you're like oh my god like he
is what is he and later on they
explained and it would work with the
movie throw out a cheesy ass line case
in point because that's what I remember
most about that fight sequence is the
shitty ass cheesy lines like forever
neat stylistic scene where the hit man's
like on his back and springs up with his
leg start shooting behind him for every
moment like that it was like three or
four five shitty moments really like
that was just dumb the movie is not
clear in what's driving its plot it's
not detail-oriented the girl in this
movie she's supposed to be really smart
too and at first you're like oh yeah she
just like deconstructs things and sees
things and sees probability kind of like
you're in a Sherlock Holmes but then it
goes so far as you're like is this girl
psychic or something when this girl sees
shows like her mind's eye does this like
iris effect where you're like oh it's
clearly what she's seeing right she can
see the hit man but she's never seen the
hit man before but she sees him walking
in the building she's like oh my god
who's that it's more than deconstruction
at that point she's getting images she
touches a dude's hand she starts getting
images again I'm like are you psychic
lady Murray doesn't do you the courtesy
because I don't think the movie knows
what it was trying to do with that guy's
Indian hitman agent 47
I enjoyed the Hitmen person himself
Zachary Quinto would have made a good
villain if he didn't have a shitty
script to work with lots of wreck it's a
mess it's not cohesive and the
one-liners are terrible some of the
action shootouts were pretty neat there
were some stylistic things that happen
in the movie were like oh that's Nate
maybe I'm not gonna [ __ ] it up about
those moments movie I would have
crucified you now I'm just gonna do the
courtesy of killing you point is hitman
agent 47 you're not gonna remember it in
t minus a couple hours yep already
forgot I swear to god at this point I
would usually write off video game
movies entirely but Warcraft has not
come out yet if Warcraft sucks forget
about it just do away with it no more
video game movies all right so hitman
agent 47 have you seen it what did you
think about it did you prefer this one
or the Timothy o a font one whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more